i find you absolutely fascinating uh and
i really enjoyed talking to everyone
we've talked before because uh i think
you and i agree on uh like the end
results and part of what uh i don't
think we disagree i think there's just
like nuance to how we get from where we
are to that end result which uh
ultimately
you you know i like to think you and i
are both rational enough to say like hey
i don't know exactly what's gonna happen
but like here's where kind of like i
think the world is going and how it's
playing out one of the things that uh is
one of those nuances that's fascinating
to me is
you talk about you're either aligned
with bitcoin or you're not or your
actions are aligned with bitcoin or or
they're not but there's no such thing as
bitcoiners and so you know i saw you
tweet this recently and i was like man
that's like pretty interesting like
explain that a little bit more as how
there's no bitcoiners but like your
actions could be aligned with bitcoin or
not
yeah i think it's an interesting lens to
it right a lot of people immediately
think that if you can be a bitcoiner
right like you can somehow represent
this as a technology uh but i think
that's not really a good way to look at
it right as as people we ultimately just
don't have
that much of an impact on on bitcoin
right it is this neutral monetary system
that operates sort of outside of us so i
think when i say
you know your actions either align to
bitcoin or they're not what i'm trying
to say is that you know i think people
look at it as a binary perspective oh
this person isn't a bitcoiner because he
said something that we don't like or oh
this person isn't a bitcoiner because he
supports these other things that aren't
bitcoin um and i like to look at my life
a little bit differently right i i try
my best to align my work with bitcoin i
try to make sure that
you know what i'm doing has a positive
impact and you know but i'm not a
bitcoiner like in every sense of the
word like i'm gonna go to the grocery
store i'm spending us dollars right i'm
not furthering the bitcoin economy in
that moment uh so i'm not aligned with
bitcoin in that moment right as a
philosophical movement that is
attempting to make change in the world
does that make me a bad person no it's
like at that moment i'm not aligned with
bitcoin and i think it's a more nuanced
perspective because i think
what we're both sort of arguing about
and talking about is this uh tendency
for people to who are really involved in
bitcoin to sort of claim some ownership
of it and use that as a way to sort of
you know attack or or target other
people uh to try to kind of
uh you know i guess bring them to the
bitcoin side right so i guess it's just
a different perspective for me right i
wasn't someone who was initially a
bitcoiner i was a journalist i was
someone who was you know essentially
paid to be quote unquote objective about
what was happening uh with the bitcoin
market uh you know but over time you
know i just felt that
you know that was misaligned and it
didn't really it and i don't really even
know today whether it's you're it's best
to describe me as a bitcoiner right i'm
someone who simply tries to align as
much of my work and human time as
possible with bitcoin but there are
limits to that and if you have some
idealistic standard you know for what a
bitcoiner is i might not live up to that
and and maybe that's okay right like
maybe there's a good discussion to be
had about how we're both perceiving uh
what is good for bitcoin and that's
maybe a healthier way to look at it yeah
what's fascinating about this is it's
almost like if you take every single
action you have throughout the day and
you were literally to score them on like
good for bitcoin bad for bitcoin
agnostic uh right
a person who is in the bitcoin community
would be trying to optimize for as many
of those actions to be good for bitcoin
uh as possible but it would be nearly
impossible to actually get a hundred
percent and so
in some way people are trying to
categorize like what do you have to have
eighty percent of the actions fifty
percent react like like what is the the
cut off for bitcoin or not bitcoin uh
but i do like this idea of um
essentially how many of the actions on a
daily basis are aligned with the asset
with the community with the network and
if you think of it that way you really
are the sum of all those individual
decisions so you start to almost try to
change your behavior uh in a way that
increases the total number of decisions
that are aligned with bitcoin
right i think that's all you can do at
the end of the day right so i think when
people have problems with quote-unquote
bitcoin toxicity or the way that
bitcoiners behave online it's often
times that they really feel that people
are just putting forward an impossible
standard right uh that nobody could
possibly live up to being the sort of
ideal bitcoiner and i think it's a it's
an interesting lens to look at it right
like who is the ideal bitcoiner is it
someone who's you know saving bitcoin
all the time and never spending anything
is it someone who's trying to further
the bitcoin network by you know actually
spending it and you know um
actually advancing the economy in some
way so i i think it's a way to look at
it by just acknowledging as you said
like the human limits of it and also you
know divorcing yourself from
you know feeling like your whole
personality or identity is uh you know
um is derived from being a bitcoiner
right there's often
there's many other things that i'm sure
interest you as a human being and every
listener here that make you you right
and i think that
um you know we sort of have this like
for us against us sort of binary uh
you're either a bitcoin or you're not
and i don't really think that's healthy
yet because i think the better
discussion is what does it mean to be a
bitcoiner right so i think when people
argue about bitcoin toxicity or the
state of the bitcoin conversation i
don't really know if they're arguing uh
about any of those things particularly
they're often arguing about you know
other tangential things such as you know
um are we you know is our is how our
online behavior like encouraging to
people is it are we promoting an idea of
what it means to build on bitcoin and i
find like those questions are much more
interesting than sort of oh is this
person a bitcoin or a real bitcoiner um
i don't know i think we would probably
both agree to start there as saying like
there's there's definitely impossible
standard and i don't know who the
perfect bitcoiner is is it michael
saylor is he the perfect bitcoiner uh
some bitcoiners would disagree right so
i prefer to look at it as you know
you're aligned with bitcoin or you're
not
and i think you should you know try to
ask yourself if you were aligned with
bitcoin and then make decisions uh
against that way and we could talk about
why that's a good lens right and why i
think it's a helpful lens is you who are
really in bitcoin uh what we're trying
to do is build a better financial system
for the world right and that if you
think that as a worthy ethical cause
then i think it's worth applying that
lens to your own life